attention film buffs here's 31 random
movie facts you need to know alfred was
supposed to talk to the Joker here but
Michael Caine was so startled by Heath
Ledger he forgot his lines Vincent and
Mia's dance is the same as Gloria and
Mario's from Fellini's eight and a half
Clint Eastwood wore the same poncho
through all three man with no name
movies without ever cleaning it red cell
number is the same number as the haunted
room from The Shining Christopher Lee is
the only member of the cast and crew to
have ever met JRR tolkien Arnold's 15
million salary 42 breaks down to $21,000
per word hasta LaVista baby George Lucas
put together this montage as a favorite
of Francis Ford Coppola for helping him
with American Graffiti Sally Field is
only 10 years older than Tom Hanks all
the animals in the matrix are
computer-generated hidden in this pillar
is an engraving of r2d2 and c3po every
piano key played on screen is accurate
no one is faking Anthony Hopkins total
screen time is only 16 minutes Neil
Patrick Harris was considered for the
role of Private Ryan the words you
freaked at the end of the sentence are
dubbed by Christopher Nolan yeah freak
this dance routine was choreographed by
Paula Abdul Martin Scorsese actually has
two cameos once here and once here the
coconut gag was used because the film
couldn't afford horses we found them
these blue lasers were borrowed from the
who who were rehearsing on the
soundstage next door Charlie Sheen
stayed awake for 48 hours to get this
look my Blue Heaven is an unofficial
sequel to Goodfellas both movies are
based on the story of gangster Henry
Hill because the screenwriters were
married this asteroid field contains
random objects including a potato and a
shoe the movie see you next Wednesday is
a running joke in John Landis's films
psycho was the first American film to
show a toilet flushing Uncle Ben's car
is Sam Raimi's personal automobile Delta
88 it appears in all of the directors
films Alan Rickman was dropped a second
early to get his true reaction the name
of the band is never mentioned once in
the entire movie cameo by porn star ron
jeremy this scene required 342 takes
this scene required only one take the
runtime of Titanic is the exact time it
took the real ship to sink and Snow
White and the Seven to
Forbes was the favorite film of Adolf
Hitler what movie do you want to know
about let us know and we'll make the
video